well tonight the investigation continues
into that deadly fire that took the
lives of two young children
it happened yesterday morning near owens
in hollywood joe moeller spoke to
neighbors who are still
curious about what exactly happened he
now joins us live joe that's right we're
still waiting on an update
as far as as to how this fire started
now this evening many are still left
completely shocked by this here in this
neighborhood we'll give you a live look
at the home
family and friends are set to gather
here for a vigil happening here
very soon for those two children who
lost their lives
it was pretty crazy there was a
gentleman over on the corner
across from the house and he just
dropped to the ground started screaming
my baby
and that's when it looked like it was
definitely much more going on there than
just a fire
the deadly fire that tore through this
east valley home is a tragedy no one
thinks will happen
someone tried to save them and just was
unable to just due to the situation that
there's really
literally nothing they could do michael
long lives down the street
a two-month-old young girl and a
two-year-old boy died in the fire that
sparked tuesday
a neighbor across the street told us he
saw a man break a window and
climb out they say he then tried to pull
the children out of the front room but
was not able to
i can't imagine it like if that's just
too much wednesday metro police along
with chaplain volunteers went door to
door to offer support for people living
nearby
neighbors we spoke with say it's a close
neighborhood and they want to be there
to help when they can
just making sure that you know that we
can
you know do whatever we can if if
there's anything literally that we can
do
now back out here live here taking
another look at the home where this fire
happened again family and friends are
set to gather here starting at 6 30
they're planning a vigil outside of this
home for those two young children now
the last update we did get from the
clark county fire department was
yesterday around midday we are waiting
to get more information is
a lot of people still have questions
about how exactly this fire started
reporting near owens in hollywood joe
mohler
8 news now